highlighting now a local business baby
birds cafe located durango and sahara
been in business now for about three
years and it's bringing more than coffee
to the valet
it is the las vegas desert but when it
comes to
this restaurant it feels relaxing in
your backyard kind of mode since las
vegas is the entertainment capital of
the world
the owner wanted to bring something what
they call cute
classy and healthy you can find coffee
smoothies
tea and healthy toast there are vegan
and gluten-free options
when the mother bird feed the baby bird
it's got to be good thing right
yeah and healthy like you eat something
good and make you
light like you can fly like a baby bird
but also i think about nature
that's quite a meal when you can fly
after aside from the delicious
and pretty food it's also uh for the
younger folks it's instagram
friendly they have a flower wall
mountain and lake views that's the way
the world is right dude
yeah gotta take a picture of your food
before you eat it these days